so we have some words here that relate
to different reactions and whether they
absorb or release different types of
energy so the first word here exothermic
exothermic the root of the word is therm
which relates to heat and this word
indeed means a reaction that releases
heat
releases
releases
it releases heat
and one way to think about it if you're
thinking about constant pressures or
change in enthalpy it can be viewed as
your as your how much heat you absorb or
release so a negative change in enthalpy
negative change in enthalpy means that
you're releasing heat one way to think
of if you view enthalpy as heat content
you have you have less heat content
after the reaction than before it which
meant you released heat which means your
change in enthalpy is going to be less
than zero so these all mean the same
thing well this this is true you're
releasing heat this is the same thing as
releasing heat if you talk about
constant pressure
constant
pressure which is a reasonable
assumption if you're doing something in
a beaker that's open to the air or if
you're thinking about a lot of different
biological systems now based on that
logic what do you think this word means
endothermic well endothermic
endothermic therm
same root and now your prefix is endo so
this is a process that absorbs heat
absorbs
absorbs heat
or if you're thinking at constant
pressure you can say your enthalpy after
the reaction is going to be higher than
the enthalpy before the reaction so your
delta h delta h is going to be greater
than greater than zero all right fair
enough now let's look at these two
characters over here exergonic and
endergonic so exergonic the root here is
ergon and that you might not be as
familiar with that as you are with therm
but you might have heard the word
ergonomic say hey that's a nice
ergonomic desk that means it's a desk
that's good to do work at it's a nice
ergonomic chair and ergon does indeed
come from the greek for work and so
exergonic is a reaction that releases
work energy at least that's what the
word implies
releases
releases let me do that in the same
color
this is something that is going to
release
release work
work
energy
energy
and endergonic same logic well that's
going to be something based on just the
word the way the word is set up that
absorbs work energy or uses
uses work
work
energy
now one of our one of our
our variables or properties that we can
use to think about energy that can be
used for work is gibbs free energy and
the formula for gibbs free energy if
we're thinking about constant pressure
and temperature so let me write that
down so if we're talking about constant
constant
pressure
pressure
and
and temperature
then the formula for gibbs free energy
you can even view this as a definition
of gibbs free energy
the change in gibbs free energy let me
do this in another color the change in
gibbs free energy is equal to our change
in enthalpy
our change in enthalpy
minus
minus
let me just send the different color
minus our temperature
minus our temperature times our change
in entropy and if this looks completely
foreign to you i encourage you to watch
the video on gibbs free energy but the
reason why this is related to energy for
work is okay look i have i have my
whether i'm absorbing or i'm releasing
heat and i'm subtracting out entropy
which is kind of the energy that is is
going to the disorder of the universe
and what's left over is is the energy
that i can do for work that's one way to
think about it and so you can see that
this relates work energy to change in
enthalpy right over here
and so exergonic exergonic something
that releases work energy you can say
that it has less work energy after the
reaction than before it your delta g is
going to be less than zero so let me
write that down
so here
our delta g is going to be less than
zero and these things these reactions
that release work energy we've seen it
in the video on gibbs for energy we
consider these to be spontaneous
spawn
spontaneous these are going to move
forward
and so these over here the ones that
absorb work energy well they're going to
have more work energy in the system than
before is one way to think about it and
so your delta g your delta g is going to
be greater than zero and we say these
are not spontaneous
so these are not
spawn
spontaneous so now that we have the
definitions out of the way and we have a
way to relate these variables let's look
at these different scenarios of things
that are exothermic and exergonic or
exothermic and endergonic and see why
they make an intuitive sense
so in this first reaction it's
exothermic our delta h is less than zero
that means it has less enthalpy after
the reaction than before which means it
released heat and so you can see here
this heat is being released and where
does that energy come from well when the
when the when it bonds in these new
configurations on a net basis the
electrons are able to go to lower energy
states and release that energy and heat
if you're thinking about it on a
microscopic scale it's something that's
raising a temperature at least locally
which it means just about transferring
kinetic energy to these to these
microscopic molecules remember when
you're talking about heat or temperature
you're thinking about these macro
variables but on a microscopic variable
you're talking about kinetic energies
and potential energies and things like
that so what's happening is these
electrons are when they get into a new
configuration and they're going to
they're going to release energy and that
can be transferred to the individual to
the individual molecules and so you see
here we've released energy and we also
have an increase in entropy we have more
entropy after the reaction than before
the reaction we have more we have more
objects right over here there's more
states in which they could actually be
in and they're actually moving faster
and so this one we see if you just apply
if you apply the formula over here this
is going to be less than zero
this over here delta s is going to be
greater than zero the temperature that's
going to be absolute temperature in
terms of kelvin so it's always going to
be positive and so this whole term
is going to be positive so you're going
to have a negative minus a positive is
going to be negative so our delta g
our delta g
is going to be less than zero and we see
that this is spontaneous this is going
to move forward and it makes sense it
releases energy the electrons like it it
creates a more disordered state i think
another way to think about it is think
about trying to do the reaction the
other way you're going to have to get
some energy for those electrons to get
into a higher energy state when they
form these new bonds you're going gonna
have to get these four constituents
together in the exact right way that
seems less like a lot a lot less likely
to happen than going in from the left to
the right
now let's think about something that
absorbs heat and this one's a little bit
counterintuitive it absorbs heat but
it's still going to be spontaneous it's
still going to be exergonic it's still
going to happen
so delta h is greater than zero so it
absorbs heat to happen so i have these
two molecules with these different
constituents they're about to collide
and we're saying that the temperature is
high if the temperature is low this
might not be spontaneous but if the
temperature is high enough it will be so
the temperature high on a microscopic
basis you're saying okay these things
just have a really high kinetic energy
they're going to ram into each other
really fast and they're going to ram
into each other so fast that they can
form all these other constituents
instead so that you have the the you
have the net entropy you have the net
entropy has increased and even though
over here our electrons are in a higher
energy state to form these
configurations so it had to absorb heat
so it had to absorb heat energy so we
could say heat but heat on a microscopic
level we're just talking about
kind of kinetic energy of of these
molecules so it have to absorb it but
where where did that where did that
energy come from well it came from the
kinetic energy of of the molecules they
might have been they might have a
certain kinetic energy before but then
some of that gets lost so when when they
all get banged up into their different
configurations and if you're saying well
i still don't get this think about
trying to do this reaction the other way
try to get these four constituents in
the right time all together even though
if they're happening if they're if
they're if they're put together the
right way their electrons could
configure in a way to release energy but
this is super high temperature this is a
really really chaotic system it's not
going to go from right to left it's
going to go from left to right when it's
really chaotic things are banging each
other really fast you're more likely to
go in a direction of of higher entropy
so now let's look at now let's look at
the so this is spontaneous even though
it absorbs heat it absorbs heat if
you're not draining the heat away
locally your your your temperature at
least around these molecules it will go
down but of course we assume we're
assuming constant temperature for this
so you could assume that you know on a
macro level that temperature dissipates
and gets absorbed outside of the system
somehow
now let's look at this configuration
it's exothermic so delta h is less than
zero less enthalpy after the reaction
than before so it's releasing heat
but it's not spontaneous and it's not
spontaneous because it's reducing the
entropy in the world it's reducing the
entropy in the world and the entropy
matters because our temperature is high
one way to look at this equation is
entropy doesn't matter when temperature
is low temperature is really scaling
your entropy but when ent when
temperature is high entropy starts to
take over this variable starts to matter
a lot and so over here because entropy
is negative this isn't going to this
thing's not going to actually happen so
if these things were coming together
very slowly their electrons could
configure in just the right way so that
they can get to a lower energy state and
release energy but they're buzzing past
each other so fast that they're not
going to have a chance to do that and if
you think about it the other way this
reaction
is much more likely to happen if you
have a bunch of these diatomic molecules
running around they're going to bump
into each other so fast that they're
going to knock they're going to knock
the constituents off of these off of
these diatomic molecules or at least the
way of depicted it kind of looks like a
diatomic molecule and they'll they might
absorb some of that kinetic energy in
doing it in order to go from right to
left but that's more likely to happen so
from left to right not spontaneous
because entropy really matters at this
high temperature
and then finally and this one's pretty
intuitive something that needs heat
something that needs heat energy and has
a reduction in entropy that's definitely
not going to be spontaneous so this is
greater than zero this is less than zero
which but when you're subtracting it so
this whole thing is greater than zero
this delta g is going to be greater than
zero
delta let me do that in that green color
this
delta g is going to be greater than zero
and it makes sense that you have these
two molecules they have to get together
in just the right way they need heat in
order to proceed with this reaction to
kind of excite to to excite the
electrons to higher energy state to get
into this i guess you could say less
stable bond why would do why would they
do that the reaction is much more likely
to go in this way where if you had a
bunch of these molecules they're all
knocking into each other they get into a
more stable configuration and there's
more entropy when there's when they when
they split up then when they actually
stay together so delta g greater than
zero this is endergonic and endothermic
and of course this one was delta g
greater than zero even though this would
release energy the the the things are so
chaotic they're not going to have a
chance to do that and you're much more
likely to go in the direction of of
maximizing entropy and so this one also
is not spontaneous